I'm really stuck right now like tell me
like I just feel insignificant you know
what I mean I just feel like I'm not
getting anything done I just feel like I
can't like
maybe a little bit but at the same time
it's actually like
kind of drowned out the voices
because is it because you have such real
ambition yeah dude that's the thing like
sometimes it's worrying about other
people think other times it's you know
you got something and you're just trying
to get it the [ __ ] out yeah exactly
which is why I [ __ ] push patience
because I had that too I didn't really
go for mine until I was 34. how old are
you 18. right so you can imagine why I
[ __ ] always want to razz you guys but
I actually think it's a good thing it's
a good thing that you feel like you got
something that you can you're just gonna
have to figure out how to somehow keep
pounding your [ __ ] head with it's
gonna come because what you're doing is
you're deploying judgment on yourself
your ambition is making you beat
yourself up because you don't understand
the timing you can say that you
understand and you could be in this line
and know what I'm about to say that's
different than actually living it you
just gotta slow it down it's gonna take
time nothing [ __ ] good comes fast